ساعود اليك ولكن فيما انت تتحدث عن كشف
الجانب الاسرائيلي عن هويه القياده
البارزه في الجهاد الاسلاميه التي تم
اغتيالها اليوم الى حد الان الجهاد
الاسلاميه لم يعلن عن اسم هذا القياديه
ولكن نحن نشاهد عمليه الاغتيال امامنا على
الشاشه استهداف شقه سكنيه في حي النصر قبل
نحو ساعتين من الان وخروج جثتين الجهاد
الاسلامي اعلن عن استشهاد قيادي بارزه دون
ان يسميه الا ان الجانب الاسرائيلي كشف
هويه من تم اغتياله في هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه مره جديده اعود اليك الياس
كنت تتحدث عن التطورات الميدانيه وعن
الرشاقات الصاروخيه التي اطلقتها الفصائل
المقاومه تفضل
بالفعل وهذه الرشقات في الساعات الاخيره
يعني منذ ساعات الظهيره وهي تتركز عمليا
في غلاف غزه القريب في البلدات
الاسرائيليه الملاصقه للسياج الامني وهي
في دائره سبعه الى عشره كيلو مترات
وبما في ذلك بطبيعه الحال مدينه ازدرات
وغيرها من البلدات الاسرائيليه لكن
التركيز كان في الساعات الاخيره تحديدا في
منطقه ناحل العوز هذه المنطقه الواقعه الى
الشرق من مدينه غزه يبدو ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
ركزت من ضرباتها بقذائف الهاون هناك على
مواقع تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في محاوله
لايقاع اصابات محدده ومحكمه بهذه القوات
المتمركزه هناك ذلك ان هذه الضربات لا
تستهدف فقط البلدات الاسرائيليه هنالك
العديد من القواعد العسكريه الاسرائيليه
والتجمع الدبابات والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه
التي يبدو ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تستهدفها كانت هنالك بعض الانباء غير
المؤكده التي اشارت الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تمكن من اسقاط مسيره حاولت
اختراق اجواء تلك المنطقه في ناحيه العوز
لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يؤكد هذه النقطه
تحديدا علما بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لديها من القدرات
الجويه ايضا ما لديها وكانت نشرت في
السابق عمليات استهداف لاليات عسكريه
ولناقلات جند تحديدا عند السياج الامني
وصورت ذلك ووفقته وهذه المسيرات فدا قادره
على حمل عبوات ناسفه مصنعه محليا وهي
قادره على القائها فوق هذه الاليات
العسكريه التي تتمركز فوق تتمركز قرب
السياج الامني ويبدو ان امرا مشابها كهذا
ربما يكون حدث هذا اليوم لكن هو غير مؤكد
حتى هذه الساعه من اي جهه اسرائيليه رسميه